le printemps prendre de l'avant ce qui
s'en plaindrait du vrai beau temps dans
de nombreuses régions de france la
chaleur de retour cet après midi dans le
sud ouest 23 degrés à albi le
thermomètre s'emballe 9 degrés au dessus
des normales saisonnières muriel la saga
olivier combe tard à lunettes allure
nonchalante
elle rend brin dégagé albi aujourd'hui
tout le monde a pris sa peau d'été on en
profite et pas se mettre à la terrasse
on n'a pas trop envie de retourner un
coup je veux pas de s'allonger au parc
rochegude comme ça ouais en allemagne il
fait aussi très beau mais les
températures sont beaucoup moins élevés
qui siège aujourd'hui à stuttgart fait
10ans degrés c est bien albi le mercure
est monté jusqu'à 23 degrés presque un
record
un degré près alors forcément après
quatre longs mois de pluie de neige et
de vent on a vite fait de s'emballer et
de sortir olivier des orangers et ça va
trop vite alors en avant en inde et en
vie on veut toujours aller vite vite
avoir son jardin sa terrasse bien
arrangé puis pof il arrive gelé certes
mais pour l'instant les bourdons en
chavire de bonheur
quant à cela le soleil ne leur a pas
encore fait tourner la tête
ils accumulent pour bronzer et nous nous
devons nous sommes sur les pontons
tranquille comme baptiste demain les
pêcheurs seront là puis après demain car
météo france annonce soleil et chaleur
pour toute la semaine